I cannot believe it is already time to
make my worst of the Year video this
year has gone by so incredibly fast if
you guys missed my best of the Year
video that is currently on my channel in
which I count down my top 20 favorite
films of the year because I simply
couldn't construct it into 10 it had to
be more there was too much goodness this
year but there was more stuff to talk
about that was not good before I get
into my top 10 worst films of 2014 I do
have some dishonorable mentions these
are movies that were awful just terrible
movies but I actually saw 10 movies that
were still worse than these I
Frankenstein the purge anarchy
transcendence transformers age of
extinction Pompeii there were 10 more
that were worse than that help me let's
just get right into it guys starting off
with number 10 it's a fucking board game
it's a board game Ouija was one of the
worst horror films of the year it's a
film where nothing happens it's just a
string of stupid dumb twists that don't
make any sense when you actually go back
and think of the entire film speaking of
really dumb horror films my pick for the
ninth worst film of the year is
Anabelle was the money leeching prequel
off of the highly successful and good
the conjuring it had none of the thrills
of the conjuring none of the suspense
none of the interesting characters
nothing that was good about the
conjuring was included in Annabelle it
was just a doll and it's directed by the
person who brought us Mortal Kombat
annihilation and the butterfly effect to
was anyone actually expecting this to be
good and why in the hell did it make any
money why did it make money why why I
need to calm down I'm only at number 9
moving right along with number 8 this
was basically scary movie 6 just without
being scary movie 6 it's Marlon Wayans
excuse to make more scary movie movies
without actually making a scary movie
movies they're not good anymore okay the
sarcasm and the satire and all of that
has worn off it's just a bunch of what
what's the famous horror movie that came
out this year oh it's that one alright
well we'll just make fun of that I mean
who really wants to watch Marlon Wayans
hump and Annabelle doll for like five
straight minutes coming in at number
seven we have now look I like Melissa
McCarthy I legitimately do like I've
seen her in interviews and she seems
super awesome super talented and very
very funny but Tammy whoa I don't know
what that was and the scariest thing
about it is it's like her and her
husband got together and made it they
were like yeah we want to make this
movie like it was like something they
were passionate about for whatever
reason when the funniest thing in your
movie is when you witness the main
character who's so annoying get hit by a
car and you know you're got a problem
with your movie man moving right along
with number six comes more annoying
characters
the other woman is a movie that is
marketed as a female empowerment movie a
movie that girls can go see feel strong
about who they are and just be happy you
know it's great right no uh the other
woman is a movie that makes women look
terrible I mean I said this in my review
I was like women don't go support this
movie it's a movie that tries to make
women look great by having them beat up
on men the entire time but all they do
is talk about men and how much they need
men and how much men have hurt them and
men men men men men and then of course
Kate Upton with her bouncing boobs how
was this a movie for women this makes
women look bad and it was filled with
terrible performances led by Cameron
Diaz this is her first and not last
appearance on this list
speaking of really dumb stupid men at
number five we have when the year began
and we realized we were going to get to
Hercules movies and that one of them was
directed by Brett Ratner and the other
one was coming out in January and I
realized that I was more excited for the
Brett Ratner film I knew something was
wrong it is shocking to me that the guy
who directed this movie directed die
hard to I don't know where this has gone
for him like what happened along the way
but this is one of the worst directed
action movies I've seen in quite some
time it utilizes the overuse 300 effect
where you go slow and then fast and slow
and then fast and it's like a basically
a horrible amalgamation of 300 and
gladiator takes all the worst aspects of
what those movies have and just combines
them into a giant explosion of terrible
acting terrible green-screen holy crap
this movie looked as if it wasn't even
finished
welcome back Cameron Diaz because at
number four we have
one of the most unfunny and difficult
comedies to watch of the entire year
this is a movie that's whole plot hinges
completely around this sex tape idea and
the fact that oh my goodness some people
might actually see this and it is
rampantly filled with so much product
placement it's crazy there's like an
entire scene dedicated to Jason Segel
throwing an iPad out of the window and
then he picks up and goes wow like these
things are really durable I can't
believe it didn't break there was
literally not one single moment in this
entire movie where I left it was also a
very tame movie for a movie called sex
tape all of the raunchiness that could
have been there seemed like it was
hidden behind the fact that Cameron Diaz
won't go that far you know if you don't
want to go there with your humor then
don't be in a movie called sex tape
that's simple now we're getting down to
the nitty gritty number three now before
any fans of the VHS franchise jump down
my throat let me say that I bought the
first two on blu-ray that's how much I
enjoyed this franchise in my previous
reviews of the other two you can
actually see me saying that I love the
fact that this is becoming a franchise
and this could make a really cool
franchise and I hope that it goes in
great directions VHS viral was not a
great direction
no it lost all of the cleverness the
first two films had any ingenuity or the
fact that it was a whole bunch of people
coming together to make really artful
and creepy shorts will lost with this
strange attempt to make some sort of
statement about viral marketing but
don't make it a VHS movie where annoying
skater punks are just skateboarding
around shooting skeleton people for ten
minutes and as I said this is coming
from somebody who really liked the first
two coming in at number 2 we have the
most recently released film on this list
and that is
Cameron Diaz is in three pics of mine
for worst of the year good job not
really no it's really easy for people to
say well you just don't like musicals
not true I like to lay miserab there are
plenty of Disney films that I like that
are highly musical I do like musicals if
they're good if they're good they're
good Hanny wasn't good it was terrible
because not only did the film fail on a
story perspective from a script
perspective from a scene to scene
perspective that's supposed to feel
cohesive as if it is one movie it failed
on that grounds but it failed on the
most important grounds that a musical
has to stand on and that is have good
music just because you can revitalize
some classic songs and add some sort of
synth pop electronic beat and make it
feel incredibly processed with tons of
auto-tune
yeah that doesn't mean your movie has
good music the singing was terrible
Cameron Diaz was fucking awful in this
movie I'm talking shit ah this movie
reduced me to like an ape just now well
guys it is now that time it is time for
me to talk about the worst film that
I've seen all year now I've seen
hundreds of movies this year so this is
really saying something one of them
stood out among the rest I saw this film
in an empty theatre not another soul was
there so I could laugh as loud as I
wanted to and groan as loud as I wanted
to when I saw
Vica Armstrong is a stuntman of extreme
fame he has done stunts for the Indiana
Jones movies this is a man I have a lot
of respect for a director know in my
original review I said there are
theatrical releases straight to DVD and
blue-ray and then made-for-television
left behind occupies some disgusting
dark damp trash filled space beneath
that I sat in utter hilarity in this
theater just watching these scenes and I
felt like I was watching a movie that
was rejected by the Lifetime channel
like they were like no that's not good
enough for us we have higher standards
than that and the one possible thing
that could have redeemed this movie is
an over-the-top crazy-ass Nicolas Cage
performance and we didn't even get that
he was just like what am I doing here I
just I I don't understand what why what
am I here what is going on I don't even
have a freakout in this movie like I
can't even be crazy what is going on
fuck I'm not even talking about the
shove it down your throat religious
aspect of this movie because I did not
see saving Christmas the Kirk Cameron
movie and I was like no okay I have
standards I enjoy my life too much to
experience that left behind stands out
by far as the worst film I've seen all
year it is a terrible abomination it
should not be viewed by anyone even
people who support the film's religious
message said that it was crap that's
something 2014 is over what that's crazy
I don't even know man that's nuts I'm
looking forward to next year though I
can't wait for 2015 and I want to give a
heartfelt thanks to you guys for
continuing to watch me for another year
for experiencing a lot of the good stuff
and a lot of this kind of stuff that
I've been talking about thank you so
much as always for watching my next
video is going to be in January it's
going to be my most anticipated of 2015
look forward to that guys and again
thank you so so much for watching you
guys are the best and if you missed my
picks for the 20 best films of 2014 that
video is also on my channel right now as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get
Darkman iced